welcome everyone
i hope everyone is staying safe and i'm
glad to see so many people trying to
learn new skills
while they're stuck at home today i'm
going to be talking about effective data
visualization
my name is kristen sennani and i'm an
associate professor at stanford
university
where i teach both statistics and
writing
i think data visualization is
particularly pertinent to the moment
that we find ourselves in
more than any other crisis that i can
remember data visualization is helping
to shape the public's understanding of
this pandemic
they are being used both to inform the
public and policy makers and also to
persuade people to change their
behaviors
i think by now everyone has probably
seen this highly influential flatten the
curve graphic
this first appeared in the economist in
late february
that graphic was actually adapted from a
2007 cdc publication
in which the cdc was planning for just
the kind of pandemic outbreak that we
now find ourselves in
but the version of the graphic that
you've probably seen
is this simpler version that was created
by drew harris a professor at thomas
jefferson university
and what he did was to remove those
notes the one two three
and to simplify the graphic by drawing a
line to indicate where we would
overwhelm
the health care system and i think this
graphic is particularly persuasive
because it's really easy to understand i
think it's helped convince people
of why they need to stay home even if
they themselves are not as high risk
and actually this is the version that's
really made the rounds in the media
i saw this on stephen colbert i also saw
it on john oliver
two of my favorite late night hosts
and actually journalists have been
tracking coronavirus cases in real time
using data visualizations such as the
map that you see here
the new york times has really done some
fantastic data visualizations such as
this map which they update daily to keep
the public informed
there are also a number of dashboards
worldwide that you can go to to track
the evolution of the pandemic such as
this dashboard from johns hopkins
university
so data visualizations are really being
used to tell the story of covid19
today i'm going to talk about what makes
an effective data visualization
i'm going to highlight some principles
of effective data visualization
and also tell you what can go wrong and
i'm also going to talk about how you
might graph the same data
in different ways to tell different
stories
i have to give a big shout out to this
reddit group data is ugly
this is a site where people can go and
post flawed graphics that they've come
across
and actually most of the problematic
graphics that i'm going to show you
today i actually found
on this reddit site so when i show you
those graphics i'm going to cite the
reddit site i'm actually
not going to cite the original authors
just because my intent is not to
criticize any particular authors
if you want a little bit of levity in
this time of stress i highly recommend
that after this talk you go to this site
and browse some of the graphics some of
them are pretty funny
also if you are homeschooling your
children at the moment
and you want to talk with them about
data visualization there are some great
examples on there
where kids can go and look at the
graphic and try to find the mistake
i'll also point out that there's a
complementary reddit group called data
is beautiful
where you can go if you would like to
see examples of excellent data
visualizations
today i'm going to highlight six
principles of effective data
visualization
this is by no means a comprehensive list
you can have whole courses in data
visualization so i'm just going to
highlight a few things that i think are
important
first you need to use the right graph
for your data
secondly you need to be accurate and
transparent
and actually there are many many ways
that you could be inaccurate or
non-transparent there could be a whole
course in
point two up there i'm just gonna
highlight a few things today
you need to use color wisely and then
points four and five
cut the clutter and convey a clear take
home message those
are verbatim principles that i teach
when i teach effective writing
so there's actually a lot of overlap
between effective data visualization and
effective writing
in both cases you are trying to convey
an idea to your reader
as clearly and concisely as possible and
then finally with data visualization you
also have to worry about
visual appeal
so i'm going to start with the first
principle here use the right graph for
the data
so i'm going to start by reviewing two
types of graphs that i know you're all
familiar with
but that you might not have thought too
much about recently so first of all
bar graphs represent numerical values by
the height or length of the bars
and they're typically used to show
frequencies and actually i dug out some
papers
from my kids i think my daughter did
these graphs maybe in second grade
on the left-hand side she graphed
hypothetical data on
book sales on different days of the week
and on the right hand side she actually
went around her class and collected data
on her classmates
about what months they were born and
then she put it into a bar graph
and i actually think it's wonderful to
see that they are now teaching
probability and data literacy in
elementary school these are things that
i did not learn in elementary school but
it's actually funny because my kids
think this data stuff is really easy
compared to doing things like
decimals and fractions and dividing big
numbers so they always say
mom you teach the easy math
and then line graphs are used to show
trends over time
or some kind of other progression such
as a trend over age or dose
and this is another graph that my
daughter did she did it for a project on
climate change this year
you can see that she graphed the average
monthly arctic sea ice
from 1978 to 2016 clearly it's going
down
as part of that project she also made
this cute little clay polar bear so i
just had to share that
so a common error in data visualization
is to choose the wrong graph for your
data
for example choosing a line graph that
really should be a bar graph
so i grabbed this example from that
reddit site that i mentioned
this was just a small survey and we
won't talk about the problems with study
design here we're just going to focus on
the graphic
but they ask people if you were to use
marijuana why would you use it
and so they've got frequencies of
different reasons
but they graph that as a line graph and
you can see that that doesn't work too
well because it looks like something is
going up
and then down as you go across the
x-axis
but of course there's actually no order
to the x-axis
so i re-graph these data to show you
that these are better
represented in a bar graph when you put
this in a bar graph it's now really easy
to pick off the frequencies of these
different reasons
you can also have bar graphs that should
be line graphs
so i grabbed this graph off of that
reddit site
this graph was actually attributed to
wikipedia
and what it shows is the last 10 world
record holders
in the men's hundred meters in track and
field
so each bar is an athlete and the y-axis
shows their times
but you can see that this really doesn't
work well as a bar graph it's very hard
to differentiate the differences between
those athletes
now i suppose if that was your point if
you were trying to show that we don't
improve much in the world record times
maybe that's an okay graphic but i
actually think
what they're trying to show here is a
progression and a progression is better
represented with a line graph
and so actually i went to wikipedia to
try to find this graphic
and by the time i got to wikipedia it
had already been replaced
with the correct line graph so on this
line graph what you're looking at
is the x-axis represents the different
athletes and the y-axis is their times
so now you can see how much each athlete
improved the world record
so you can see that the biggest
improvement was between tyson gay
and usain bolt another way to graph
these data would have been to use dates
on the x-axis
if you wanted to show say how quickly
the world record was falling over time
one other thing to point out is notice
that this y-axis does not go down to
zero
and some people have the misconception
that all y axes always must go to zero
that's not in fact the case if you're
doing a bar
graph you do indeed need to go down to
zero because these bars need to be
proportional to the times
but if you're doing a line graph where
you're trying to show the relative
differences between these times
it's actually okay not to start at zero
so that you can zoom
in on these higher times
here's another graph that i grabbed from
that reddit site so this was looking at
worldwide life expectancy from 1955 to
2015.
and the average life expectancy
worldwide was 52 years in 1955
that increased to 72 years in 2015
but i'm not quite sure why that is being
represented as a
spiral doesn't really make a lot of
sense as a spiral this would have been
better represented as a line graph
where the x-axis went from 1955 to 2015.
here's an example of a pie chart where
the data really don't belong in a pie
chart
so they were asking people about their
biggest covid19 worries whether getting
it themselves their family getting it or
the economy
but if you look over at this pie chart
you can see that we have 68
62 and 48 well those clearly don't add
up to be a hundred percent
remember that in a pie chart you need
mutually exclusive categories that add
up to 100
well in this case probably what happened
is they allowed people to check off
multiple worries
so these are not mutually exclusive
categories and they are not well
represented in a pie chart you'd be
better off with something like a bar
graph here of course there are many many
other types of graphs beyond bar graphs
pie graphs and line graphs
i'm showing you a few of my favorites
here that i use a lot when i'm analyzing
data
so on the left hand side is a scatter
plot that's used to show the
relationships between two continuous
variables
on the upper right hand side that's a
histogram which is used to show the
distribution of variables
and i love histograms if you ever take a
statistics course with me you'll see
that i have
lots and lots of slides with histograms
on them
in the bottom right that's a box plot
also used to show the distribution of
variables
i do recommend that if you do a box plot
that you superimpose those
individual data points so that you can
see the individual level data
by the way all of these graphs are
really easy to make in programs like
sas and r
the second point here is be accurate and
transparent
there are lots of ways that you can be
inaccurate and
non-transparent so today i'm actually
just going to focus on one of the most
common ways
that people lie with charts
so edward tufte is considered the father
of data visualization and he wrote this
classic book
the visual display of quantitative
information and in it
he puts forth several principles of how
to be accurate
when you're making graphics one of the
most important is he says
the representation of numbers as
physically measured on the surface of
the graphic itself
should be directly proportional to the
numerical quantities measured
for example if you make a bar graph then
those bars need to be proportional
to the numbers they represent and you'll
see this is one of the most common
mistakes that people make one of the
most common ways that people can mislead
you with graphics
i'm going to show you some examples now
here's a really interesting graphic that
i pulled off of that reddit site
this is showing american deaths by
disaster
911 hurricane katrina benghazi ebola
hurricane maria
and coveted 19. and these occurred under
three different presidents
bush obama and trump and you can see
that clearly the authors of this graphic
were trying to convey a message to you
they are trying to tell you that things
were really bad under obama
but it's pretty easy to pick up the
mistake on this graphic in fact i showed
this one to my children to see if they
could figure out the mistake and they
were easily able to pick out the problem
here
the problem is that these bars are
completely not proportional to the
numbers that they represent
the 4 and 2 bar are gigantic much much
bigger
than the 16 000 bar for covid 19.
of course this graphic was made a few
weeks ago and we now have many more
deaths
from covid19 so what i did was to take
these data and re-graph them
into a proper bar graph in which the
bars are proportional to the number of
depths
and you can see when it's graphed
correctly it gives you a
totally different visual story
here's a graph that was displayed on cnn
a few weeks ago
and it's showing coronavirus cases
worldwide it shows 80 000 for italy
80 000 for the us and 81 000 for china
but what you'll notice is that the bar
for china is about 50 percent bigger
than the bar for the u.s this gives you
the impression that there are many more
cases in china compared to the us
but i re-graphed these data into a
proper bar graph
and you can see that the story looks
very different when graphed correctly
there isn't really much difference
between eighty one thousand and eighty
thousand
this one is pretty funny uh this one is
showing average female heights in
different countries
and you can see the average height in
india is five feet and in latvia it's
five feet five
but there are a couple of problems with
this graphic so first of all this is the
type of bar
graph and so the y-axis actually does
need to go down to zero
such that the heights of these figures
are proportional to the actual heights
this also has a second problem though
they are not only using the heights of
these figures to represent the numbers
but they are also
increasing the width of these figures
and so now
area rather than height is being used to
visually
represent the numbers and that's a
problem because you can see that the
area of the figure from india is about
10 times less
than the area of the figure from latvia
giving you the visual impression
that latvian women are 10 times as tall
as
indian women this is a graph that
appeared on nbc
back when we were worried about the zika
virus they asked people how concerned
they were about the virus and they could
answer very somewhat not very or not at
all
but you can see that something went very
wrong when they put this into a bar
graph because somehow the 25 bar is
bigger than the 28
bar and the 13 bar is bigger than all of
them
so i think someone just messed up on
this one
this is a graph about what the european
union is asking its members to pay
the current contribution was one percent
of gdp and they were asking for an
increase to
1.08 percent of gdp well that's an
eight percent increase but you can see
that the bar on the bottom
looks almost twice as big as the bar on
the top
this gives you the mistaken visual
impression that the increase is much
bigger than it actually is
the next principle is that if you're
going to use color on your data
visualization
you need to use color wisely in
particular if you're going to use a
gradient of colors to represent
counts you need to choose the right
color scheme
this is a map from fox news that was
showing confirmed cases of coronavirus
this is from a few weeks ago
but you can see that the color scheme is
a little bit problematic here that
bright yellow color really jumps out at
you making you think that there are
a lot of cases in those areas but in
fact yellow represents below 10.
also there are four different types four
different shades of
red being used to uh represent
50 plus 100 plus 1 thousand plus and 10
000 plus cases
now i don't know about you but i cannot
differentiate those four shades of red
so it's impossible for me to tell where
there are 50 cases versus 10 000 cases
just to show you that the same mistake
can happen on the other side of the
political aisle
here's a graph from msnbc that has the
same error
in this case they represented the
highest category
with a very light color and so when you
look at the map
it gives you the visual impression that
there are the fewest cases in new york
and lots of cases elsewhere in the u.s
when in fact new york has the most cases
the fourth principle is cut the clutter
and this is something
that i also teach when i teach writing i
try to get students to
strip their sentences of all unnecessary
words
with a data visualization it's the same
thing you need to strip your graph of
all unnecessary lines words tick marks
and
elements here's a graph that i
grabbed from that reddit site that is
obviously overly cluttered
it's really hard to make heads or tails
of this graph because there are just so
many elements on it
even if we had a legend available that
would help us to decode some of this
there's just so much going on that it's
really hard to make sense of
here's another overly cluttered graph
this is showing different sectors of the
economy in different countries
but you can see that so many of these
words are overlapping that you can't
even read them
and then there's just so much going on
here it's really hard again to make
sense of
we can also go back to this flat in the
curve graphic that i
started with at the beginning of this
talk the left
hand version that's the version from the
cdc on the right we've got the simpler
version created by drew harris
and you can see that the cdc's version
is more cluttered it has this one two
three and then these little notes that
you have to read
so this graphic is going to take longer
for a reader to process
whereas the graphic on the right you can
instantly get the take-home message i
think that's why this particular graphic
has been more influential in the
pandemic
now of course as with any form of
communication you always have to think
about who is your audience
so arguably if you are making a graphic
for other scientists perhaps it's okay
to have a little bit of extra detail
but certainly if you are trying to
communicate with the public you want to
make that graphic as easy to understand
as possible
the fifth point here is that you need to
convey a clear take-home message
and this is exactly the same thing as
when you write something
before you sit down to write something
you need to know what is it that you are
trying to tell the reader what is your
take home message if you don't know that
you're not going to be able to
communicate anything clearly to your
reader
well it's the same with a data
visualization you actually need to have
in your head a take-home message
you're not just throwing a bunch of data
on a piece of paper you're actually
trying to construct something
that tells your reader a message so you
have to have a clear idea of what that
message is
before you go to build that data
visualization
i also grabbed this graphic from that
reddit site and it's asking how
contagious is coronavirus
there's a number of things that are
problematic with this graphic so first
of all i'm not sure why
they are representing these data with a
pie chart there's really no reason that
infectivity of different viruses would
lend itself to a pie chart
why would those add up to 100 i'm not
sure
i'm also not sure what the numbers mean
they're given as percentages but i'm not
sure why the infectivity of the virus
would be a percentage
maybe this is some some kind of relative
infectivity of different viruses but
i'm not sure and then finally
i'm not really sure what the authors
wanted me to take away from this graphic
are they trying to show me that
coronavirus is
not that infectious compared to other
viruses
or are they trying to show me that it
has a similar infectivity to
other flus i'm not really sure that they
knew
what they were trying to convey when
they built this graphic so i'm unable to
walk away with
a clear take on message this graph is
about
marketing knowledge and learning but
it's actually quite
dizzying there's a lot going on here and
i'm having trouble making heads or tails
of this graphic i really can't figure
out what it is that the authors were
trying to convey here
now here's an example of a well-done
data visualization
with a clear take-home message this is
actually often pointed to as an example
of excellent data journalism
it comes from the wall street journal
and it's showing cases of measles
the rows are different states and the
columns are different years
and you can see that there's this nice
dark line where the vaccine was
introduced in 1963.
this tells a very quick visual story you
can see that there was a
large drop-off in the cases of measles
after the vaccine was introduced now if
you scroll out to about the year 2003
you'll notice that there's a little bit
of an uptick in measles cases
and in fact this graph only goes until
but i bet if we were to graph it out now
to 2020 you would see
an even bigger uptick and that's of
course due to
vaccine deniers
here's another example of a graph with a
clear take-home message
this was posted recently on 538.com
and this is graphing data from different
polls that were conducted between march
and april
asking americans whether or not they
trust the cdc
on covid19 and you can see that
they mostly do trust the cdc about 80 to
90 percent of americans say they trust
the cdc
versus about 10 to 20 percent who say
that they distrust
the cdc
the final point here is that if you're
doing data visualization
you also have to worry about making it
visually appealing
now i am certainly not an expert in
design there are people who
study design principles i'm just going
to share with you a couple of examples
of what i find
more or less visually appealing this is
a dashboard from the singapore
government for covid19 and you can see
that it's
quite elegant right it's on this nice
white background it has these pleasing
colors it's not overly cluttered it
reminds me a little bit of like an apple
computer design so i find this one
quite visually appealing
contrast that to the covid19 dashboard
from the hong kong government
now there's nothing wrong with this
dashboard statistically the numbers are
just fine
but i find it a bit less visually
appealing it's a little bit more
cluttered i don't really like the black
background and the neon colors
it just doesn't have as much visual
appeal to me
the last thing i want to talk about here
is the point that
you can correctly graph the same data in
many different ways
to tell different stories
i'm going to use covid19 as an example
to show you a couple of different
statistical and design choices that you
can make
when graphing your data in order to tell
different stories
this first example shows the difference
between representing counts as
height or length versus area so on
april 6 this graph on the left-hand side
was published in the new york times and
i found it quite visually striking it
caught my attention
this was actually an interactive graphic
and we haven't talked about interactive
graphics today
but i'll note that a lot of the online
data visualizations for covid19 are
actually interactive you can hover over
things to see
specific case counts in specific states
or they show videos
where you see the evolution of things
over time and so the
graphic on the left here was a little
video where you could see the total
number of deaths
growing over time and the number of
deaths is represented with these red
spikes it's represented with height
now on the same day in the new york
times deaths were are
also plotted with this map that you see
on the right
and the numbers of deaths were
represented with areas with circles
and you can see that these are visually
quite different
now of course you might argue that the
graph using area to represent f that the
scale was very small they used small
circles to represent death counts and
also
those circles were not colored but i
pulled from
the new york times that same day this
graph which they used to represent case
counts so you can imagine that if we
represented the deaths with bigger
circles and we turned them red this is
about what it would look like
so now we kind of have a more fair
comparison to compare
the depth counts with height versus with
area and you can still see that there's
a visual difference here
the human brain processes height and
length differently than it processes the
area
we actually have an easier time
processing length and height than we do
area
so i still think that the graph on the
left is more dramatic it's more visually
striking
and that's because it's representing
numbers with
height rather than area another choice
you have to make
when graphing coronavirus case counts is
whether or not to graph them on a linear
scale
or a logarithmic scale and just to
remind you
a linear scale means that one tick mark
on the y-axis represents one case so
here we're going from 100k to 200k to
300k to 400k
in contrast on a logarithmic scale those
tick marks correspond to powers
so here you can see that we start at 1
that's 10 to the power 0
and then we go to 10 that's 10 to the
power 1 then 100 is 10 to the power 2
then 1 000 is 10 to the power 3 so those
lines actually represent
powers rather than absolute counts
both of these are perfectly correct ways
of representing the data
they just tell different stories they
just highlight different aspects of this
virus
so if you graph things on a linear scale
what you're going to see are these
nice exponential curves if you are
trying to convince the public that this
pandemic is about to explode then you
might want to choose a linear scale
a logarithmic scale gives you different
information though if you graph things
on a logarithmic scale that
tells you something about the rate of
growth
if you have a straight line that would
mean that there is a constant rate of
growth for the virus
if you have a line that curves upward as
this
bottom line this bottom orange line this
is the us at the beginning of the
pandemic you can see that it's curving
upwards
that means the growth rate of the virus
is increasing
with time and then this blue line is
china and you can see that that curve is
bending downwards that means that the
uh growth the rate of growth of the
virus is actually
decreasing over time and that's what
people mean when they say bending the
curve this is this blue curve has been
bent
china was actually able to bend the
curve and get the growth rate down to
zero you can see that actually the line
becomes flat or horizontal after a while
another choice you have to make when
graphing coronavirus cases is whether or
not you want to
leave those case counts unadjusted for
population size or whether or not you
want to adjust for population size
and so i took these screenshots a couple
of weeks ago and you can see that
at that point in the pandemic china
that's that blue line if you look at the
top
left graph that is not adjusted for
population size
so the total counts of cases was similar
at that point
in china as to other countries in the
world but you can see that if you adjust
for population size
over here on the bottom right that line
for china drops
compared to the large number of people
in china
the burden in china was relatively less
than other countries in the world even
at that point in the pandemic
now i've seen it hotly debated on
twitter as to which of these is more
correct than the other in fact
they're both just fine they just answer
different questions
so if you want to know something about
like how many ventilators are you going
to need
then you want to look at absolute case
counts not adjusted for population size
however if you want to say something
about how well a particular country is
doing in controlling its pandemic
and the total burden or total impact on
that country
then you're going to want to adjust for
population size because of course
countries that have more people
have greater potential to have large
numbers of cases so you need to take
that into account
my take-home messages are data
visualizations can be highly impactful
as we're seeing during this current
pandemic data visualizations can also be
used to intentionally or unintentionally
mislead people
an effective data visualization avoids
distortions and manipulations
it also follows principles of effective
communication
just as when you're writing you want to
convey an idea to your reader as clearly
and concisely as possible
and then finally i made the point that
the same data can be represented in
different ways
to tell different stories
if you want to learn more about data
visualization i have some
books here that i would recommend so
edward tufte is the visual display of
quantitative information is a classic
i also like albert carroll's book on how
charts lie
if you want more of a primer about how
to actually make these visualizations i
i would recommend karen healy's book uh
for a journalist
perspective knowledge is beautiful by
david mccandless is good
i also um already mentioned those two
reddit sites so if you just want to
browse some examples of
good and bad data visualizations i
highly recommend those two reddit sites
for those of you looking for more online
training while you're stuck at home i do
offer some other resources
so first of all i write a statistics
column for the journal pm and r
you can access those columns at the link
there and those cover
different specific topics and statistics
so if you want to learn about principal
components analysis
or logistic regression or instrumental
variable analysis
or topics and data visualization such as
scatter plots
box plots and histograms you can go
there i try to make those very readable
if you'd like some further online
training in medical statistics
if you'd like to learn how to analyze
your own data and make data
visualizations in sas nr
as well as learn about basic concepts in
probability and statistics
i recently launched a certificate
program in medical statistics i'll say
a bit more about that in just a second
here and then finally
as i mentioned before i also teach
writing so if you want to learn to be a
better writer
i offer a course called writing in the
sciences on coursera
and the link to that is there as i
mentioned i recently launched a
certificate program in medical
statistics that involves three courses
in medstats one we'll teach you how to
do basic programming in sas or
r there is no previous experience in
programming required we will start you
right at the download and help you from
there
that course also covers uh descriptive
statistics and
some data visualization med stats 2
covers probability and statistical
inference
such as p-values confidence intervals
and bayesian inference
i'll show you how to use sas and r to do
computer simulations to illustrate
some of those concepts and then finally
in med says three
i cover specific statistical plots and
tests that are used
for certain types of medical data
if you're interested in the certificate
program and in those courses the link
for that
is here and you can go and check that
out
thanks everyone for watching stay safe
and i hope to interact with a lot of you
online in the future
you